what's going on here right are you
trying to my job oh hey didn't tell you
we're trying to keep things fresh okay
first of all it's kale and second of all
fresh what's not fresh I'm gonna let you
do the intro you can't do it new in
theaters this weekend Ilana and
book-smart what will you see this is
your weekend ticket okay yeah that was
pretty good
[Music]
there's a Cave of Wonders
bring me the land
Aladin live on the big screen this we
get this live-action adaptation of the
1992 Disney animated film tells the same
story of a street rat turned prince
through the magical assistance of a limp
dwelling genie he pursues a princess any
evil sorcerer wants a genie for himself
just another Monday for life hey can you
make me a prince there is a lot of gray
area in make me a prince I could just
make you a prince Oh No this movie is
for you if you're a fan of the original
Aladdin Will Smith playing the genie
cures your blues or you want to be shown
a whole new world shining shimmering
splendid
Oh what's this for just wanted to say
thanks for having me on the show and to
make sure we're cool
I see what you did there like a DQ
blizzard yeah we're chill I figured with
all these amazing summer movies coming
out what would be better than sharing
some of my favorite summer Buzzard menu
items
caramel can involve lizard from my
favorite candy oh thanks
would you say that it's been ice working
with me yeah sorry
it's the last day we got you through
high school I need to go fan with your
budget numbers man we just graduate head
off to college that should do it I can't
hear you
I can't soundproof glass also on
theaters this weekend a book smart this
fun teen comedy directed by Olivia Wilde
follows two overachiever high school
seniors who realize that the kids who
partied got into just as good if not
better colleges thinking maybe they work
too hard in high school they try to cram
for years into one epic night hand
sanitizer happy chapstick mace listen it
is very important that you keep the
safety it's Lady Bird meets super bad
but it's also super good and I'm excited
for it
you'll like this movie if you like
teenage coming-of-age movies you're
looking for a feel-good friendship movie
this weekend or you got straight A's in
high school or you did
Ariana are there any other movies you're
excited about this summer yes
I'm really looking forward to see the
life aside sir she specializes in
behavioral disorders but I don't have a
behavioral disorder
yeah I'm fine two hits by humans it's
nuts I mean you know I I bring him a
dead bird she throws it out and direct
sequel to the first which I also look
since release on June 7th it's full of
fun characters and hilarious tuna pet
life situations who is your favorite
character probably digit she's a fluffy
Pomeranian who in this movie is trying
to learn how to be a cat it takes a lot
of acting range to play a dog playing a
pet it potentially award-worthy
performance eat sweet pea what cats eat
birds you're seriously gonna make her
eat sweet Pete no bad dog bad cat dog oh
sorry this movie is for you if you
enjoyed the originals you could like the
pets you've always wondered what's your
pets get into when you're not looking or
your pet is the cutest pet which is
impossible because my dog Duke is your
kids pet sorry not sorry
that is your weekend ticket what Willie
is it and check back next week for more
summer trees thank you it's really nice
working with you
hey that's my joke
[Music]